what you need to know today begins at
the epicenter of the national football
league and last week there was so much
stirred up in indianapolis scouting
combine about the future of tom brady
and everybody who's in this business i
mean let's peel back the curt for a
second everybody who's in the business
of covering the nfl wants to be ahead of
the curve on tom brady it created a
feeding frenzy last week he created a
circular firing squad last week there
was resentment there was acrimony
there's jealousy there's this there's
that everybody wants to be one step
ahead of where this tom brady story is
going and that has resulted in plenty of
people reporting that he's going out of
new england
our good friend tom curran of nbc sports
boston has tried to apply some
rationality insanity to the situation he
has an item that you can find at the nbc
sports boston website we've written
something about it at
profootballtalk.com as well
tom brady patriots chris sims
not
as inevitable that it's going to be a
divorce as some seem that doesn't mean
he's staying
but it's not like he's got a bag packed
and one foot out the door and the other
one off the ground and there was a sense
last week that that's where it's heading
yeah there's still a chance that you
know when it's time for him to get down
to business with the patriots he's going
to realize i've been here half my life
yes it is a big deal to uproot
everything i know everything i've done
everything about my routine year in and
year out and go somewhere else where i
have no idea what it's going to be yeah
that's exactly right i mean that would
be the first thing i would think of i
mean first off we're in unprecedented
you know uh waters here a cat you know
area i mean it just
tom brady greatest of all time
what he's not back with the patriots i
mean it is crazy and i think you're
right everybody at the combine is so
anxious to get an answer get a feel here
there's a lot of interesting things to
kind of unpack here i mean yeah you know
okay it does seem like new england is
willing to let him go out there and test
the market i get that yes all that also
you know i don't know how many teams
that are out you know out there in the
quarterback market definitely want tom
brady you know right now i mean i feel
like the only two teams we can really
like say okay you know the tennessee
titans maybe the tampa bay buccaneers
from what we heard bruce aryan say i
mean i all know we have this wishful
thinking with the 49ers and you know i
see peter's column yesterday and what
you write so okay maybe i don't know
about that so that's the other
interesting aspect of this whole thing
because there are some teams that are
quarterback needy this year
but do you really want a 43 year old at
this point of his career and then no
you're gonna be back in the same boat of
needing a quarterback maybe a year or
two from now that's where i go on the
radio and talk to people mike i just
still stay i think it's 55 45 60 40 that
brady ends back up in new england this
is my biggest reason you go somewhere
else and it will be the hardest off
season in tom brady's career since his
rookie year and does he really want to
go through that does he really want to
go somewhere and like you said carve out
his new path with a new franchise move
his family okay then deep dive into a
playbook and probably have to learn a
new language that he's never had a deal
with and then really learn it to where
he could be tom brady like he's been
with the patriots those are some really
tough challenges those are life
challenge life-changing challenges it
would be
a grueling work moving your family
you know unknown territory as far as the
team's concerned and i always just say
why you know again you know i don't i
don't want to see tom brady in anything
but a patriots uniform i want to go why
you know he's still good and i think
that he can still lead them to a super
bowl and i think that they'll get
weapons around him this year to help him
out yeah i think about that reality new
team new city new teammates new coaching
staff new offense new everything the
stress of moving your family on top of
it right and
and
yeah the idea that was floated by tom
curran a week or two ago and i'm not
saying this is incorrect i'm willing to
accept tom curran's report completely
that tom brady is considering having
interested teams come to him
if i'm tom brady
don't i want to go there don't i want to
see what it feels like to walk into a
new facility don't i want you know when
you like shop for houses yeah right you
know when you walk through the door
whether or not you want to live there or
not can i envision myself being here can
i envision myself working here what's
the locker room look like what's the
training room look like what does it all
feel like because the last thing you
want chris and i went through this more
times in my life than i'll care to admit
the last thing you want to do is pull
your car into the parking spot at your
new place of employment look up at the
doors and say what in the hell have i
done and at that point it's too late to
undo it so i don't know about this idea
of tom brady sitting on a throne where
one team comes in after another and
makes their pitch i want to go to this
facility and that facility and that
facility and the other thing to keep in
mind
we have to be considering the reality
that not every team that's interested in
tom brady is going to be willing to wait
that's right sure this is the time of
year where the teams say we got to know
what you want to do because if you don't
want this offer we're moving on to the
next guy and the next guy until we find
the guy that that wants to to play here
uh how many teams are going to be
willing to defer to tom brady taking a
week or so to figure out what he wants
to do i think that's it's you're right
it's very dicey it's a very real part of
this situation you know and again it's
not like we're talking about tom brady
who's 32 years old and he's in the prime
of his career and you're going okay
we'll wait because we might get you for
eight or ten more years or something
like that in free agency we're talking
about waiting for a guy when there's a
lot of other options that are out there
that are maybe better or not you know a
little a little less than okay but in
the general vicinity to where yeah are
you going to sit there and wait for
brady if he needs 10 extra days to mull
over a decision you know yes i think
that is dangerous for teams and they're
going to have to weigh their options
there you know the other thing too you
just look at is you know when you go to
new england with brady too i'll bring
this up one more time josh mcdaniels
being back i think that's huge i think
people are making a bigger deal about
the fact that new england hasn't talked
to tom brady yet yeah i do you know
that's not the way belichick is i think
that when things come to a pinnacle here
and it's getting close to the start of
free agency and brady's got a real feel
for what he might get on the open market
or what situations are out there i think
new england will then call and be like
hey tom we we want you back you know we
just
we had a mull over some things we never
denied we didn't want you back
you know i think there's the price the
situation everything's got to be right
there and i think ultimately that's what
will happen they'll end up being back
together i just don't see brady doing it
all you know
it i i would not be shocked and i think
some of this comes through in tom
curran's column
i wouldn't be shocked to find out that
the patriots have already made those
communications with tom brady yeah
they've been text messages sent that
that brady knows the patriots want him
the question is what will ultimately be
the terms the one thing from last week
that i thought was a little bit on the
bogus side the idea that the two sides
didn't meet at the scouting combine
because until we know what's going to
happen with the collective bargaining
agreement there's no reason to meet
because they don't know how the deal
could be structured look there's two
options what the deal would be if there
is a new cba what the deal would be if
there isn't it's not like an entire menu
of potential contracts that you have to
negotiate and you know what you can
structure and what you can afford to pay
if there isn't a new cba and you know
how you structure it and what you can
afford to pay if there is i mean these
other you think these other teams that
are interested in tom brady said last
week well we'd love to meet with don yee
but we can't do it until we know what
the new cba is going to be i mean that
was bogus on his face totally they
didn't need to meet last week last week
was about tom brady finding out who else
is interested so that now this week and
next week at some point there could be a
meaningful conversation with the
patriots regarding what's behind door
number one because he already has a
pretty good idea of what's behind door
number two or three or four or however
many total doors are out there for him
to walk through if he chooses to do it
well
and you know to more of what you're
saying yes i mean you know you mentioned
it you know okay yeah teams are going to
come visit him all right great yes
that'll if that does happen i think at
some point to what you're saying he's
going to go visit other he's going to go
to that facility and check it out i
think before he signs there but like
here here's another thing like tell me
right now like legitimately all right
mike i know we know people in the nfl
everything like that who who do we think
is really interested in brady right now
like who do we think that the market is
like what are the teams we're talking
about we're talking about who the
tennessee titans the tampa bay bucks
the chargers who have kind of you know
kind of hiding in the weeds right now
and not making any
you know comments and then who else not
to be confused not to be confused with
hiding in the weeds hiding in the weeds
right yes right the
the raiders the raiders okay right right
and then are we talking about anything
anybody else that legitimately
back to the point that i was making
earlier about which teams have the
luxury of time right the ability to go
through this dance right um the raiders
are at the top of the list yeah because
they've got derek carr
and it's already out of the bag that
they're interested in tom brady it's not
like having brady go to las vegas or
going to see tom brady is going to make
derek carney more upset he already knows
so the raiders are best suited followed
closely by the chargers because they've
got tyrod taylor though i think deep
down they'd like to upgrade over tyrod
taylor especially going into that new
stadium right but the 49ers have the
luxury of time as well now they may not
want to upset the psyche of jimmy
garoppolo by courting tom brady before
deciding to stay with jimmy garoppolo
but they have until april 1 that's when
jimmy garoppolo has 15.7 million in
salary become fully guaranteed and the
49ers have always built that into their
veteran contracts and one of the reasons
you put it there is to use it right at
some point you're going to use it yeah
and this is a year that they could use
it and you know i think that that
if it ever gets to the point where tom
brady is visiting the 49ers i think it's
already done right yeah it never gets
that far everybody knows that we can't
stop and turn back right and and the the
fact that he was a 49ers fan growing up
would allow him to avoid that feeling of
what have i done because he's pulling in
every day to the facility where the
49ers are he's going to be happy with
that he's going to make it work but
these other teams well and the 49ers are
in that bucket too with the chargers and
the raiders they can afford to wait and
see what tom wants to do the titans are
going to have to figure out what the
hell they're going gonna do they got
ryan tannehill right and if you let
tannehill go and you go after tom brady
and you'll get him who's your
quarterback gonna be marcus mariota and
the same thing for the buccaneers if
they go after tom brady and they don't
get him
and and jameis winston's gone who's
their quarterback going to be so you
know we're operating under the
assumption that this game of musical
chairs is going to result with more
butts than seats there's still a chance
that they're going to be teams at the
end of the day that are settling for
somebody a tier or two lower than what
they could have had if they had moved
more quickly yeah well yes and there's
no doubt about that but you know then to
like the raiders and and the chargers
point like
you know
again is tom brady really going to want
to go there that's that's where i go to
like i don't think this decision
or move
is about money i think it's legacy i
think if he goes anywhere he's going to
go to somewhere where he thinks it gives
them a chance to go win one more super
bowl and say
huh i can win without bill belichick i
don't need him you know and the raiders
that's not happening right now it's not
happening this year maybe two years is
brady willing to go somewhere and go
like i'll be part of a rebuild for a
year and then that second year when i'm
44 we can do it and go on the super bowl
run i don't think so the chargers is he
willing to do that there i don't know i
don't know either you know
and also with those two teams the
chargers and the raiders i just have a
hard time believing just at face value
he's going to pick either one of them
why
because number 15 in red and yellow is
in that division and he's going to go
screw that i got to deal with him i'm
not going to the afc west so i almost
want to cancel those two teams out and
that's where it goes back to the 49er
thing you know when i hear you and peter
king and deion sanders who's been
beating that drum like it just makes me
think one of you guys know something
that's all that's all i'm to say i mean
i i don't know anything no but i don't
know anything i never know anything
life's easier that but but i i just find
the 49er brady conversation interesting
there i mean gosh if that happens what
what goes on does new england you know i
saw deion sanders say yesterday's new
england call call the 49ers and say
we'll take jimmy garoppolo back i mean
that would be the the greatest like
makes sense it makes sense makes a lot
of sense it does trade him right back
but all right we gotta take a break fine
take a break before we go i rarely read
from anything i've written at
profootballtalk.com but i think this
encapsulates exactly where this is and
then we'll move on does tom brady want
maximum money he never has right does he
want to win he always has brady
consistently says his favorite ring is
the next one and above all else he'll be
looking for the place where he can get
one more or maybe more before father
time finally tells him it's time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports